So how can we fix this problem? Well, the first thing
we should think about is, well, can we give a base case.
All right. All of the recursive definitions we had. We had a
way of stopping. So, we had a base case. Right. With, factorial,
we said, we are going to pre-define, that we know the value
of factorial when the input is 0. We know that the value
is 1. We are not going to define it, in terms of factorial.
We are going to note it's value. We did this for palindrome we
said, palindrome, we have a base case, when the input
string is an empty string, it's predefined as a palindrome We
don't have to do anything else. And we did this
for fibonacci, where we had two bases cases? But for all
these definitions, we had some starting point, that was not
defined in terms of thing we are defining. And that's why
it was good recursive definition, because we had the base case.
We don't have one here. So let's try to invent one.
Let's suppose that we made our base case. So if
we're going to fix this, what we need to do
is invent a base case. Maybe that will solve our
problem. So let's try and add a base case. So.
Suppose we assume we know the popularity of Alice and
sadly Alice is not very popular. Her popularity score is
a 1. So that looks like a base case, right
we define the base case for factorial for 0 for palindrome
for space. Let's pick Alice as our base case
now. And. That works like this for the mathematical
definition. For the python code, what we would need
to do is add the base case, as in a
statement. So we would insert a line here that
says that if p is Alice, return Alice's popularity
score which is our base case which is 1.
So this looks more like the recursive definitions we've seen.
Now we have a question. See if this
actually works. So the question is, would this definition
work? The possible answers are, only if everyone
is friends with Alice, only if no one is
friends with Alice, only if, from every person
in the network,. There's some way that you can
follow links that eventually reaches Alice. Only if there
are no cycles in the graph. So there's no
way to start from one person and end
up at the same person by following friendship's, by
following friendship links. And the final choice is no,
that there's really no situation where this works well.